[موسيقى] دعني أخطط لأفضل ما في السفر ، فهذه قائمتنا السنوية لأفضل الأماكن والأشياء التي يمكن مشاهدتها للعام المقبل كانت مختلفة تمامًا عن جائحة covet 19 ، لذا أردنا التركيز على ما شعرنا أنه الأهم من ذلك عام وفلسفتنا هي أن السفر يمكن أن يكون قوة من أجل الخير ، تعكس الموضوعات الثلاثة لمجتمع الاستدامة والتنوع تلك القيم المشتركة ، يحاول الحرث صياغة مستقبل مستدام وهو يفعل ذلك من خلال أشياء مثل أم بالاو يتعهد أن يحرث كل زائر مطلوب للتوقيع على هذا التعهد الذي يشير إلى أنهم سيكونون واعين بالبيئة عند زيارتهم ، كما أنه يهدف أيضًا إلى أن أكون أول وجهة سياحية محايدة الكربون في العالم ، ويتم ذلك من خلال استخدام برامج تعويض الكربون وسلاسل الطعام المحلية [موسيقى] تعد مدينة غوثنبورغ موطنًا لمنتزه ليسبرغ الترفيهي الذي يعد واحدًا من أكثر مدن الملاهي استدامة في العالم ، وقد احتلت جوتنبرج المرتبة الأولى في المصنفات العالمية.  على مؤشر الاستدامة منذ عام
2016.
يعمل الآن 95 من وسائل النقل العام بها على
الطاقة المتجددة و 94 من فنادقها
معتمدة من البيئة
[موسيقى]
تم منح كوستاريكا جائزة الوجهة التي يسهل الوصول إليها ،
كما تعلمون ، تُعرف كوستاريكا منذ فترة طويلة
بأنها وجهة مغامرات مع
غابات مطيرة  والشواطئ
ومزيج رائع من العجائب الطبيعية ،
لكنه مزيج من
اللوائح المحلية ومنظمي الرحلات الذين
يقدمون تجارب يسهل الوصول إليها لجميع
أنواع
المسافرين ذوي الإعاقة ، والعديد من
الحدائق الوطنية الأكثر شهرة في البلاد
يمكن الوصول إليها بواسطة الكراسي المتحركة مع منحدرات
ومسارات  التي
تعتبر مثالية لمستخدمي الكراسي المتحركة
، طور منظمو الرحلات أيضًا أشياء
مثل
ألواح التزلج على الأمواج المعدلة التي تسمح
للمسافرين ذوي الإعاقة
بتجربة ثقافة ركوب الأمواج في كوستاريكا ،
لذلك أنا هنا حيث بدأ كل شيء حبي
للسفر الدولي
حصل جيف على قصة رائعة يدير هذا
الموقع  تسمى
يوميات ممتلئة تقدم
معلومات عملية أه إلهام و مؤيد  توصيات القناة
للمسافرين ذوي الحجم الزائد ، إنه يمكّن
المجتمع حقًا من رؤية المزيد من العالم من
خلال لقاءات المجموعات
ومزيجته الملهم من التصوير الفوتوغرافي
والمقالات ، وهو حقًا صدق جيف
وانفتاحه بشأن حياته على الطريق
الذي أعتقد أنه يصنع حقًا إيجابيًا
لقد
أثرت كثيرًا ، لذا اعتقدت بالفعل
أنني وصلت إلى القمة ولكن لا يوجد مثل
ثلاثة آخرين للذهاب
[موسيقى]
كما تعلمون لأن جزر فارو
بعيدة جدًا
ويحتل المجتمع الصغير مركز
ثقافتهم  صغير في الحقيقة أنه في
أي مكان تنظر إليه تقريبًا ، ستكون قادرًا على
رؤية المحيط ،
ولكن بقدر هذا الإحساس بالمجتمع ،
يمكنك أن تتنزه على طول ، ثم
تتم دعوتك إلى منزل شخص ما
لتناول فنجان من الشاي أو شيء ما
لتناول الطعام ، ولهذا السبب حقًا أردنا
تسليط الضوء على جزر Faroe باعتبارها
جائزة الانغماس في المجتمع هذه ،
نحن واثقون حقًا من أن هذه القائمة
ستقدم تقريرًا عن أفضل الأماكن
والتجارب والأشخاص و
الأعمال
التي يجب رؤيتها في عام 2021